j'estime qu'on comprend qu'on est dans
une ère de postes vérité et les faits ne
compte plus désormais une grande partie
de ce qu'on lit sont des fausses
informations des faits qu news comme
monsieur trump aime à nous le rappeler
est souvent à juste titre mais dans la
situation actuelle il ne s'agit même pas
de la poste vérité mais plutôt de la
poste logique
ce qui veut dire l'ensemble des
accusations implicites contre la russie
et plus précisément contre le kremlin
s'inscrivent bien dans le cadre de ce
monde post logique
ce serait pure folie de la part du
kremlin ou de monsieur poutine de faire
du mal à monsieur navalni pour des
raisons évidentes qui se sont traduites
aujourd'hui dans la réaction de
l'ensemble de l'europe occidentale est
des états unis
ils se sont alignés comme de nombreux
canards tout comme précédemment en face
à la sphère litvinenko la sphère skripal
la sphère du vol m h 17
ils se sont alignés tous comme des
canards comme si tout était déjà
orchestré
il accuse la russie exige que la russie
prouve son innocence si monsieur poutine
voulait enlever monsieur navales menées
comme une épine dans le pied
il y avait tant de moyens pour le faire
[Musique]
mais voilà on a une tentative
d'assassinât à cette blessure grave à
l'aide du novice choc
il y aurait pu tout aussi bien laisser
sa signature vladimir poutine sur le
front de navalni c'est tout à fait
absurde